The Department of Justice has uncovered
a sprawling college admissions scandal.
While condemnation has justifiably rained
down on the rich parents who paid bribes,
the colleges in question are equally
culpable. College staff were complicit
in these schemes or asleep at
the switch. These same colleges won't
abolish legacy admissions or stop
reserving seats for the kids of big
donors. If admissions offices can't
detect corruption and colleges can't
stop selling access, maybe colleges can't
be trusted to judge merit fairly.
So, here's a modest proposal: Elite colleges
can put their money where their mouth is
when they talk about democratizing
opportunity, take a page out of the K-12
charter school playbook, and switch to
lottery admissions. Any applicant with a
high school credential would have an
equal shot at admission. Admittedly, this
would be a huge blow to the prestige of
elite colleges, a pain for corporate
HR departments, and a giant bummer
for the college prep industry.
But I think we'd survive. How do you think
we should reform college admissions?
Let us know in the comments. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.